[Music]
relax
[Music]
drop all describing
[Music]
sink into the i am
aware of awareness
[Music]
relax
get comfortable
situate yourself in a space
where you can adequately
turn inward
by giving yourself the right container
you create environments that
maximize your ability to
realize your true nature
so give yourself that gift
of creating a space that is maximally
alchemical for you
and once you're situated comfortably
in a quiet space
relax
really tune into the difference between
when
your mind is racing between
thoughts and beliefs and
ideas and describing
versus when you are just aware that you
are aware when you are literally
just relaxed your entire
nervous system is just calmed
down
use the breath as
the tool that assists you
with the process of calming down your
nervous system
rather than being insensitive about the
breath
make it feel like every time
that you inhale
and exhale that it
feels like making love
really tap into that right now
as we do an inhalation and exhalation
make it feel like the very
essence of the inhale and exhale
is making love is ecstatic
all right let's do it together ready
inhale
[Laughter]
and exhale
and relax deeper
into just being aware of awareness
no mind running us around from thought
to thought
and let's take another inhale
really feel like you're making love here
and
exhale
the very nature of the inhalations and
exhalations
provide us with a lot of
chemoelect
atomic chemoelectomic
signature of
feeling relaxed but we've become
insensitive to it
so the chemoelectroconnectomics are what
are going on
on a neural signature level and every
single time that we take a breath
we have just trained ourselves
insensitively to not
feel the incredible
bliss and peace and relaxation that the
very
conscious breathing gives us
so now that we're relaxed and situated
uh
the very netty netty approach
of recognizing one's true nature
has been taught for thousands of years
now the nature
of the approach is
quite different than other forms of yoga
so yoga means union
mysticism means union what are we
talking about
union with what with god with the
absolute
in order for you to recognize yourself
as god as the absolute
we need to undergo a process
called neti nutty which means not this
not that
it's also called negation
many people have heard of the classic
inclusion
the very unity consciousness or
cosmic consciousness
universal consciousness
the approach to unite that way
is helpful
i would like for us to take this
negation
and give it a whirl
in helping us understand
our true nature
so the most important aspect to this is
what is called
ahamkara which means identity
so as siddhar meshwar
said as you think so you are
so are you your name
so take the time right now
with your eyes closed in a comfortable
position
relaxed and focused on your breath to
tune into the very question
am i my name
leverage the breath
to relax into the very question
am i my name
is the nature of my very
awareness
is the nature of my witnessing
the nature of my observation
the nature of my seeing is the nature of
that
atlas is the nature of that
your name is the nature of that your
layer of identity called your
name
you secreted out of the planet
and were ascribed a name
are you the force
behind
the very creation or are you
the layer of identity
that was ascribed to you as your name
do you see the very subtle difference
am i the creationary force
behind this entire exploration
or am i the layer of identity
of my name that was ascribed to me
very very subtle
so now what we need to do is we need to
decline we need to negate
the very layer of identity that we are
most
attached to which is our name
negating our name
is paramount it is the very
first step that is mission critical for
us to be able to move on with the not
this not that negation
meditation so
very confidently negate
that you are your name negate
i am not atlas i
am not my name i am not that
layer of identity i am not
that
take the time to breathe
and to negate i am not that layer of
identity i am not
my name confidently
and now you'll see that what is left
when you decline your name when you
negate your name is you become
more subtly aware of the
very formless awareness
so now you become identified
right this is all about identity you
become identified with
the subtle formless awareness
rather than the onion layer
of identity of your name
which was ascribed to you okay so now
we've taken this massive leap inward
thanks to
our alchemical container and thanks to
our
will and choice our very desire to want
to know our true nature
is enabling this catalytic awakening
process
be grateful for that
your seeking impulse is the truest thing
about you
okay so now we're much more subtly aware
of our awareness
now we're going to decline being
the body i
am not the body
i am not this
vehicle now again you can make the very
subtle distinction of
i am the creative force
behind all reality
and i'm not this localization
in this body
later in the process what you do after
this
negation
in union in yoga is you also
include we'll go through a radical
inclusion process
as well but we need to go all the way to
source first we need to go all the way
to our true
nature first so decline
the vehicle itself
the very vehicle that you've been
attached to
for all of the years of your life
decline it negate it i am not my body
okay but where do you go you go deeper
more subtly into your
awareness the very observation the very
witnessing
the very seeing
right so now you're able to create this
juxtaposition
where you're the awareness and you're
not the body and you're not your name
and the next step is to say that you're
not even the mind
you're not the mind and you're not it's
thoughts
perceptions and sensations
you're not the beliefs you're not the
emotions
and you're not the objects that you are
perceiving
either okay this is a big step
we're gonna use the sky and cloud
analogy here
so the sky is the awareness
and the clouds are the thoughts
the perceptions the sensations
the emotions the beliefs and the objects
notice how the thought will appear
as a cloud and then it will disappear
and you are the awareness the sky
itself in which the thought appears
and disappears so we create
this juxtaposition purposefully
for us to be able to
more subtly connect to
the awareness and identify with the sky
rather than the clouds
all right relax even deeper into that
subtlety of awareness take a breath
and exhale and relax
into the formlessness of awareness
itself
not the mind and how it jumps you around
from cloud
to cloud
the very pure bear empty awareness that
is the sky
so become just the bear
just the pure awareness the very
empty awareness itself that is
the sky
now what i want us to do next
is that we've said that we are not
our name we are not our body
we are not the mind and the thoughts
and perceptions and sensations we are
not that we
are the subtle formless
awareness we are that
and you should be feeling a lot less
dense and a lot less
physical and you should be feeling a lot
more
subtle
and now as you relax
remember you have dropped the describing
of experience itself and you are just
with the very
empty awareness itself just
that stay comfortable stay relaxed
stay in a quiet environment
and stay focused with deep earnestness
and desire
to know your true nature
it's very natural for a thought cloud
to appear and for us to begin getting
wrapped up in the thought cloud but the
whole point of the game
of union of yoga is to take a breath
as you catch yourself in the thought
cloud
and bring yourself back like you're
snapping yourself
back deeper into the subtlety of
awareness that is witnessing
the cloud thought arising and passing
okay now
i would like us as we're
relaxed into that very subtle formless
awareness
eyes closed relaxed
using the breath i want us to creatively
visualize
the entire planet
take the very macro level bird's eye
view of the entire planet
okay so as you're viewing the entire
planet
and you're abiding as the very formless
subtle awareness i want you to
visualize all
8 billion humans
all 8 billion units all eight billion
costumes all eight billion vehicles
and i want you to become aware of their
awareness
so what you should be doing right now is
you should be imagining yourself
as becoming aware of all
8 billion vehicle awareness
so you're taking a very impersonal
a very shared awareness
perspective
okay so now it's getting interesting
because now you're no longer
[Music]
just your personal awareness
now you are not your personal
awareness so you've dropped the
identity of being a personal awareness
and now you're the macro level bird's
eye view
planetary awareness that is all
inclusive
and you're holding all 8 billion units
awareness at the same time
we're going to call this the impersonal
shared
awareness the very impersonal
shared awareness
and as you go through this process
you can visualize
the very thin
tethers the very thin
invisible tethers all eight billion of
these
thin invisible tethers
and you can imagine them elevating
from the very top of the planet
all connecting to one point
so now you can see eight billion
invisible thin
tethers that are
all being brought up to
one centralized point so this is the
very
all inclusive awareness point
you are no longer your personal
awareness you have negated your personal
awareness
and you are now the impersonal shared
awareness and it's all being tethered up
all eight billion awareness is being
tethered up
to one centralized point
now what i want you to do is to
take another breath
relax back into that very all-inclusive
impersonal awareness at the most
macro level
remember our identity has shifted to
that
and just take a moment to celebrate how
far
away you are from your name take a
moment to celebrate how far away you are
from your body
and the mind's thoughts look at how
well you've done you've done an
incredible job look at how far you've
come
already now you're abiding as this
massive macro level impersonal
all-inclusive awareness and now what i
want you to do
is i want you to from that macro level
awareness perspective i want you to look
at planet earth from that very macro
level impersonal
shared all-inclusive awareness look at
planet earth
and see that planet earth is
but one of your
creations it's one creation
that you witness that you
observe so this is where we start
getting into
eternity this is where we start getting
into infinity
so you are the agent the very
all-inclusive impersonal agent the
capital s
self the very god realized
perspective of the impersonal
all-inclusive awareness
and earth is but one of your creations
that you're witnessing so now i want you
to get
into a position of identity where you
begin identifying yourself
as an eternal
impersonal awareness a
infinite impersonal awareness
so you are the agent now
this is our new identity as i am the
all-inclusive impersonal
awareness agent
that observes infinite creation
earth is just one of my creations
so now you can really start feeling this
very
impersonal all-inclusive awareness
at this very macro level tether point
where it's
all combined into one centralized point
earth is just one of your creations that
you
are witnessing
so hold on to that identity that is way
macro level way subtle and way formless
and it's eternal and impersonal the key
is that it's eternal and impersonal
it's eternal and
impersonal
you are observing one of your creations
earth is one of your creations
okay now what i want us to do
as we hold this very macro level eternal
impersonal all-inclusive awareness
we can also call that the great i
am so you've shifted away from your
personal i
am to the very great i am that combines
all 8 billion awareness into one macro
level tether point
congratulations on getting here this
is massive beautiful
so take another breath
and relax again
and stay focused with a great amount of
earnestness the most earnestness
and intensity and focus and seriousness
because you are here to recognize your
true nature so now you are holding this
very
macro level eternal impersonal
all-inclusive awareness of the great i
am now
what i want you to do is i want you
to turn the great i
am the eternal
impersonal all-inclusive awareness
that's at that very macro
high level tether centralized point
i want you to turn that centralized
point
into an object and transcend it
just take a deep breath
and just abide in whatever you're
experiencing right now
the very nature of turning the most
macro level subject
into an object and transcending
even it
this is the very first
attribute of source of
the absolute this is the very last
attribute that one needs to transcend
in order to be able to recognize
one's true ineffable
nature that is even the source of
awareness itself you are
even the source of the great
all-inclusive awareness
you are the source of the great i am
that is your first attribute
your very first attribute is the ability
to
see the ability to know the ability to
experience the ability to witness to
observe
to be aware so now
identify with that which makes
awareness possible
identify with that which makes awareness
possible
say it to yourself i am that which
makes awareness possible
i am source i am
the absolute that makes awareness
possible take a breath and reflect on
that
you are the source that generates
the great i am you are the absolute that
creates that very first attribute of the
very centralized tether
of awareness that then beams down
across all these invisible lines to all
of the 8 billion units
you are the source of the great i am you
are the absolute
generating the eternal
impersonal shared all-inclusive
awareness
itself so again take a deep breath and
relax
into the awareness of that
relax into yourself as
source relax into yourself as becoming
identified
with the absolute
and become excited because you've
recognized yourself as the highest
i am the highest i
am absolute i am
source of infinite
possibility my true
nature is the source of infinite
possibility
i am fat
the very nothingness and the very
infinitude itself i
am that
i am the very no thing
shunya void no self and i
am the all self the absolute
infinitude of all possibilities of
creation
all big bangs all witnessing
of creationary dynamics of creationary
leela of all of the different
possibilities of divine plays
i am that which manifests that
now abide as that
take a breath
and relax
and bring yourself back to the source
i am the source
i am the absolute i am that which
makes awareness and makes these
creations
and immerses myself inside of them in a
hide seek forgetting remembering eternal
divine play
in exploration of myself
i am only that i am only
the creator i am only the one infinite
creator
that is my nature
i am recognizing i am remembering
my true nature as the one infinite
creator as the very source of infinite
possibilities
as the highest that manifests
all of the creationary leela
all of these 8 billion units
in this hide seek forgetting remembering
divine
play and earth is just one
of my creations earth is just one of my
explorations of these eight billion
units
in this very graph theoretic
dance of nodes and relationships between
those
nodes that is what i am i am the very
white
network theory that is dancing
around on the planet
i am the white network theory that is
dancing
around on the planet
take your breath
relax
into knowing that you are the source
of all of that white network theory that
is playing
on the planet
the very process of forgetting and
remembering
of hide and seek
you are the creator you are the absolute
you are the highest you are the source
of infinite possibility you are the very
nothingness and infiniti
simultaneously you are
that say it to yourself
i am that
i am that
i am that
i am the source of infinite possibility
i am the absolute i am the highest
i am that which creates
awareness
i am that which creates these worlds
and witnesses the white network
theory that plays
and just relax into that knowing
relax into the knowing that you are that
which
generates the great i am you
make the all-inclusive
impersonal shared eternal awareness
possible you are the generator of that
and you generate all of the different
costumes
all of the different forms all of the
different experiences
that the white network theory plays with
in these dreamed creations and
leverage the dream analogy for yourself
as you abide in the netting eddy
meditation
leverage the dream analogy where
similarly
to when you go to bed at night
and you begin simulating a dream
a reality what happens is you simulate
the environment aka
planet earth and you simulate the
observer
the awareness and immerse yourself
into the awareness or the observer
and then that is your dream experience
the very aware
witnessing of the reality that you've
simulated
and then you snap back to being in your
bed
and then you realize you are
that very absolute here the same
where you dream this beautiful creation
design exploration
and immerse yourself as the very great
i am awareness into the units
in a very dynamic
observation and playful process
so abide as the creator
abide as the absolute
abide as the one infinite intelligence
that you
are abide as that identify as
that re-baseline your identity to
that rather than your name
i am not my name you are so far away
from your name right now
you are so incredibly beautifully far
away from that egoic onion layer of
identity that you were told
and indoctrinated and ascribed when you
were born
beautiful look at that look at how far
away you are from that name
you are so far away from even the body
and the mind and its thoughts and
perceptions and sensations
you even transcended your own
personal awareness to the impersonal
eternal awareness and then you became
the source you became the absolute that
even makes
awareness possible and that makes
the creations
in exploration so you
are that source look at how far away you
are
from what you are indoctrinated into
that is the power
of the netty netty meditation that is
the power of the not this
not that approach that has been used and
that has been awakening people to their
true nature
for thousand plus years
abide a
bye take a breath
and simply abide
that means bring your attention
repeatedly
over and over again to identifying with
source
to identifying with the absolute
repeatedly
i am the creator i am the source i am
the absolute i am the infinite
intelligence i am
that which makes
all possible
do that repeatedly and you will
recognize
your true nature and re-baseline
your identity to the highest
which you are in which you've simply
forgotten you've become intoxicated
by maya by the illusion by the dream
by seeking externally for peace and
happiness when the very nature
of you as source as the creator as the
absolute
of course your nature is happiness and
peace
as that but when you're stuck
in your tiny little personhood
as your name when you're stuck there of
course you're not going to recognize
yourself as the creator you're not going
to recognize yourself
as nature as peace and happiness you're
going to try and get
objects and experiences and
relationships and substances in maya in
the dream delusion to try
and make you happy
so re-baseline yourself like gym
repetitions
re-align yourself repeatedly over and
over and over again
abide abide abide repeatedly
to the identity of yourself
as the creator i am the creator
i am the source i am the
absolute
do that repeatedly those are your gym
repetitions
now take a breath
and relax
and let's practice that gym repetition
right now
did you just try and jump back into one
of the lower
layers decline it negate it right now
you are
not those lower layers you are only the
absolute
highest you are only the source
you are only that which makes all of
this possible you are
only that and abide as that
abide as that realign yourself to that
those are the gym repetitions
now what i want you to do as you're
learning about
abiding and you're learning about this
shift
into realignment with your true nature
and doing the gym repetitions to
literally
identify yourself with the creator
with source with the absolute repeatedly
is i want you to begin
to throughout the day
notice everywhere you look that you
are what makes this
every single day i want you to look
everywhere and see that you are what
created this
you are the very source you are the very
absolute the very infinite creator that
made
all of this as one of your
expressions you created the awareness
and the world to play
you created this entire
incredibly beautiful dynamic white
network theory in order for you to play
with yourself in order for you to
explore
and so everywhere you look
all the way from that most macro level
great i am perspective all the way down
to the tiny
little ant to the leaf on the tree
to the engagement you have at the
grocery store
every single one of those experiences
is your creation
abide as the
knowledge that you are the creator abide
as the direct
realization of yourself as the creator
of yourself
as the source of yourself as the
absolute
and everywhere you look abide
as it and often as possible
recognize and re-baseline yourself to
that very
true infinite perfect nature that you
are
this is but one of your explorations
this is an appearance of eternity this
is an appearance
of infinity know yourself as that which
generated this entire appearance of
infinity this entire
appearance of eternity
and as you're abiding as the source
what you can do is you can begin
including not only the very nothingness
and the very infinitude all possible
creation designs
and all possible white network theory
lila
divine plays that are happening with all
these different
units and all these different
civilizations and all these different
worlds
so include that so now we're doing the
inclusion process the first thing we did
was the nettie nettie all the way from
your name
to the source and now we're going to do
the radical inclusion
process which is including
the fact that you generate the awareness
the very great
i am all-inclusive impersonal eternal
awareness that is the witnessing
of the creation that you generate and
now you can include
the world you can include the 8 billion
units you can include the 10 million
species you need you can include the
civilization you can include the
governments
the economies the politics you can
include
all of the experiences that are
happening you can include
all the way down to the tiniest little
subatomic particles you can include
everything including
your person identity now you can
properly include your personhood you can
properly
include your unique costume
now you see you were unable to include
your unique
costume before because you had never
broken out
of your personhood you were attached to
your name no longer you are
no longer just your name now
you are the source of all
and you are the unique costume
you are this beautiful firework you are
this beautiful spark of the infinite
and all of us are these beautiful sparks
of the
infinite never ever compare
or judge the beauty of these different
fireworks
you will immediately feel lack and you
will immediately feel the need to be
validated
and you don't need that that is a
personhood phenomenon that is a
phenomenon of your conditioning
and of your ego and of your psychology
you don't
need that what you need is
to be the source
relentlessly abide as the source because
guess what the source
guess what the absolute guess what the
infinite creator
does not need it does not need
validation from other costumes
and it does not need to comparatively
judge
between its fireworks
so take a breath
and relax into the knowledge that you
don't
need to comparatively judge the
fireworks of the infinite relax into the
knowledge that you don't
need
to seek validation from
other fireworks of the infinite because
you are all the source we are all the
source we are all the one infinite
creator
endlessly expressing itself
so now you've included your unique
firework you've included your unique
costume okay cool so there's this atlas
unit over here and there's all these
other cool names and
forms and costumes and appearances and
each one of those is one
firework in this beautiful endless
eternal infinite fire working
and now that
i am aware of my true nature as the
source
now that i am aware of my true nature as
the infinite creator as the absolute
now i can treat all
of these eight billion fireworks
and every single one of these
interactions and experiences
that i have i can treat it all like it's
divine
lila it's all the divine play it's all
the white
network theory of my own creation
i am never unsafe because this
is my creation take a breath and reflect
on that
i can never be unsafe
because this is my
creation i
am the creator i am the source i am the
absolute how could i
ever be unsafe i am
already divine perfection ineffable
divine perfection
you can never be unsafe repeat that
i can never be unsafe
and repeat it i can never be the victim
repeat that i can never be
the victim i can never be unsafe i can
never be the victim
i can never be unsafe i can never be the
victim
say it two more times with me i can
never be unsafe
i can never be the victim one more time
i can never be unsafe i can never be the
victim
this is my creation say that with me
three more times
this is my creation
this is my creation
this is my creation
abide as the creator
abide as the source
abide as the absolute
you are the generator of this entire
creation and the beautiful
dynamic playful creative
exploration that you are having with
yourself on it
now reflect
on how it becomes impossible
to be malevolent once you know this
information
once you have united yoga
mysticism hypnosis once you've
united with your true nature
how could you possibly commit
malevolence
against yourself
that's why the number one delphic maxim
is know thyself because
when you know yourself as the source
as the creator you'll never
commit malevolence against another
because
you'd be committing malevolence against
yourself
so it's the immediate eradication of
suffering they are gym repetitions
but you can see where this is heading
the more people that know their true
nature
the more we get through these gym
repetitions and we accelerate the pace
at which we eradicate suffering
and that we maximize our prosperity
here
so take a breath
and relax
into abiding as
that which can never be unsafe
as that which can never be a victim
abide as that which can never
possibly commit malevolence against
another
expression of itself
abide as that which knows that all of
this
is your creation it is all my creation
as
source it is all my creation as the
infinite creator and because of that
the best thing that i can do with my
life
is to align myself to my highest
calling my very greatest excitement
what is that highest excitement for this
firework of infinity what is it
reflect on it i as the creator
am including this firework of infinity
and what is this firework of infinity's
highest
calling what is it
is your highest calling for people to
experience god's love
is your highest calling for people to
experience themselves as the creator
is your highest calling for people to
experience
truth is your highest calling for
other people to actualize their callings
you see how by accessing this highest
calling of your highest excitement and
aligning yourself
divinely transcendently single-mindedly
single-focusedly on that north star
and dropping everything else that you
will become
the absolute greatest firework
expression that you can be
because you become in pure service to
yourself
because as you serve others you serve
yourself
as the creator
so take a breath
and relax
into the beautiful knowing that you
now have this incredible tool
of a neti neti not this
not that meditation that you can
repeatedly use for yourself
to move away from your name and away
from your body and away from your mind
and its thoughts and perceptions and
sensations
to the very formless subtle personal
awareness
and then to become aware of the
all-inclusive
great i am shared impersonal
awareness and then to become aware of
that as an
attribute of what you are as
the absolute of what you are as the
source
of what you are as the one infinite
creator which is creating the great i
am it is creating the all-inclusive
awareness
it is creating the
infinite fireworks and creations
and you are your beautiful
created expression
you are also that you've included
yourself as this beautiful firework
expression
at the same time as you've negated your
way
up to source you've included
your unique firework costume and you've
aligned yourself to a divine
transcendent noble aim calling that you
radically align your life to
in service to others because you know
that you are serving yourself
as source yourself as the infinite
creator
so now use this tool and abide
use the netty netty negation
and use the inclusion and use
the calling use these tools
to recognize and re-baseline
yourself to your true nature
to maximize our well-being
and our actualization here
okay so now take a deep breath exhale
and relax
take another deep breath
and exhale and relax
and we're going to do this a couple more
times on the way out
take a deep breath
[Music]
keep relaxing and breathing
[Music]
tap into the fountain of ineffable
perfection that you
already are
you already are the ineffable perfection
you are the source that creates this
abide as the identity of knowing
yourself as
source
of knowing yourself as the creator
really feel that breath and how every
single one of those breaths is ecstasy
is bliss peace love light unity
you are the creator you are the source
you are the
absolute
i love you
because i know you are me
abide as how you now know malevolence is
impossible
unsafety and victimhood is impossible
you are that which makes this entire
creation possible
and that is all
do the gym repetitions
abide that is all
adore you infinitely because i adore
myself we are all source
we are all the one infinite creator
thank you
as you know leverage the tool
that was shared in the show
share it with other people that you know
it would positively
influence like the video
helps the algorithm subscribe if you
haven't
leave a comment below with how this neti
neti meditation
went for you the negation the inclusion
the calling all of those components
and abide repeatedly
this is the absolute
you are the absolute
you are the creator you are the source
you are the generator of all of this
i love myself
i love all of my leela all of my
creation
abide thank you
you